para crear una cuenta en khan academy lo
primero que hay que hacer es ir a ese
punto khan academy punto org al ir a
esta dirección vamos a tener esta esta
pantalla en donde nos da la opción de de
abrir una cuenta como estudiantes como
maestros o como papás
nosotros vamos a abrir en esta ocasión
una cuenta como maestros entonces vamos
a hacer clic en maestros inicien aquí
si ustedes ya tienen una cuenta colocan
academy lo único que deben hacer es
iniciar sesión y utilizar su nombre de
usuario y su contraseña que le asignaron
a su cuenta
si ese no es el caso necesitamos abrir
una nueva cuenta entonces vamos a
registrarnos de tres maneras se puede
registrar con a google se puede
registrar con facebook o bien con el
correo electrónico en esta ocasión vamos
a seleccionar correo electrónico hacemos
clic en correo electrónico aquí vamos a
colocar nuestro correo electrónico
a continuación vamos a colocar nuestro
nombre y apellido
y finalmente vamos a crear una
contraseña les sugiero que utilicen
contraseñas sencillas y fáciles de
recordar para que no tengamos el
problema de que se nos olviden una vez
que estamos listos damos clic en
registrar
y esperamos unos minutos
y se abre la cuenta nueva nos da la
bienvenida y se nos abre esta ventana ya
dándonos la opción de comenzar a crear
nuestras clases
antes de hacer esto vamos a revisar un
poco nuestra página principal en esta
tenemos las clases si yo hago clic en
clases me va a dar todo el listado de
las clases que yo voy a ir creando en
estudiantes todos los alumnos que tengo
en mis clases desde esta página
principal puedo agregar una clase y si
yo voy a mi nombre hago clic en mi
nombre y me obtengo esta este menú de
opciones
si yo hago clic en configuración
este menú me va a permitir modificar mi
cuenta desde aquí puedo cambiar mi
nombre aquí puedo especificar mi género
masculino femenino la lengua principal
de mi clase y puedo cambiar la
contraseña vincular esta cuenta con mi
cuenta de google con mi cuenta de
facebook o con otro correo recuerden
siempre guardar a sus cambios también
aquí puedo seleccionar si mi rol como
tutor pero también como estudiante si yo
voy a utilizar la cuenta para ambos
roles desde aquí también lo selecciona
y en esta página también puedo eliminar
mi cuenta
si vuelvo a hacer clic en mi nombre se
observan tenemos aquí la opción de
página de inicio del aprendizaje esa
página así si yo hago clic me va a
llevar a mi página como alumno para
comenzar a aprender si yo
hago clic en nuevamente
en
agregar estudiantes en mi perfil él me
va a regresar a mí
roll como un maestro
muchas gracias